[Music]
the religion known as Islam originated
in the seventh century of the Common Era
in Arabia in the city of Mecca a center
of trade at which gathered diverse
peoples including those from the Jewish
and Christian faiths at the center of
Mecca was a cuboid structure known as
the Kaaba according to Muslim traditions
the Kaaba was first built by the Prophet
Adam and then rebuilt by the Prophet
Abraham for the worship of the one God
Allah however by the 7th century the
Kaaba had turned into a major pilgrimage
site where different Arab tribes
venerated idols some of the residents of
Mecca rejected the worship of idols
prominent among these was Muhammad's son
of Abdullah who was known in the city as
the trustworthy in the year 610 at the
age of 40 Muhammad was on retreat in a
mountain cave during the month of
Ramadan when he is said to have been
visited by the angel Gabriel who
commanded him recite and revealed words
which Muhammad felt had been written on
his heart these revelations Muslims
believe continued over the next 23 years
and eventually came to be collected as
the Quran they declared that God is one
overturning the polytheistic foundations
of 7th century Arabian religion they
also questioned the economic
inequalities of society by calling for
social justice and particularly the care
of the poor and orphans reminding people
that they were accountable to God for
their actions the Quran declares itself
to be the latest in a long line of
revelations from God to humanity
explicitly affirming the truth of the
Torah the Psalms and the Gospels and
teaching about faith through stories
about Moses Joseph Mary and Jesus and
other prophets the Quran states that the
message of divine unity is universal for
God has sent messengers to every nation
and people tradition places the total
number of prophets at 124 thousand in
the Quran Muhammad and his followers as
well as the previous prophets and their
followers are all called Muslim a word
that literally means a person who has
submitted to God understood in a general
sense everything in the universe is
Muslim in its
into the Creator silently singing his
praises Muhammad began his mission
teaching to a small group of followers
in Mecca but soon found himself
ostracized by the Meccan aristocracy who
were unwilling to part ways with the
traditions of their forefathers in the
year 622 facing severe persecution
Muhammad fled from Mecca to the Oasis
city of Yathrib now known as al-madinah
al-monawarah the City of Light or simply
Medina this event called the Hydra or
emigration marks the beginning of the
Islamic calendar in Medina Muhammad was
able to organize his followers into a
community for the first time he
negotiated both war and peace with the
meccans and the surrounding tribesmen
eventually conquering Mecca in the year
630 by the end of Muhammad's mission he
had provided what the Quran calls a
beautiful example of the way to live in
accordance with God's will which Muslims
from then until today have endeavored to
emulate when Muhammad passed away in 632
there were disagreements among his
companions about succession and the
nature of political and spiritual
authority in the course of time these
would lead to the split between what we
today call Sunni and Shia Islam other
forms of diversity within the Islamic
community or AMA would develop over the
centuries early Muslim leaders and
dynasties expanded the borders of
Islamic civilization through to Spain
Central South and Southeast Asia Africa
and even into Eastern Europe in the
process is Lama concepts were adapted to
local contexts at times accepting ideas
and modes of expression from traditions
as diverse as Greek philosophy and
Confucianism the ever developing
traditions of faith practice and
spirituality unfolded as Muslim
communities emerged and evolved in
diverse settings across the globe Muslim
traders mystics scholars poets rulers
and architects all contributed to the
shaping of distinctive regional cultures
as trans regional Islamic notions and
traditions interacted with local
communities to produce distinctive forms
of law statecraft theology art
architecture and science like other
world religions Islam too has been
invoked to support and the
demise diverse and even contradictory
values for example interpretations of
Islam have been used to both liberate
and oppress women or to promote peace
and provide arguments for war in more
recent times Islam has been utilized by
a variety of nation states to legitimize
a range of political ideologies as a
result the experience of being Muslim
today is often deeply influenced by the
political context one is living in
diversity of interpretation has always
been an essential aspect of the Muslim
experience as particular groups have
turned towards different individuals for
guidance from religious scholars to
members of the prophet's family
considered divinely appointed to
spiritual guides who teach through the
sanctity of their characters and the
wisdom of their insight it is helpful to
think of Islam in terms of both unity
and diversity Muslims believe in one God
Allah whom they worship and conceive of
in different ways the Prophet Muhammad
provides the single most important model
of how Muslims should live an exemplary
life of faith but there are diverse
understandings of how this model should
be followed the single most important
text in Islam the Quran is interpreted
in diverse ways and for diverse purposes
and as a single Muslim community that is
diversified through cultural contexts
beliefs and practices and their diverse
authorities who may follow
[Music]